woof - poker thumbnail
you
[Laughter]
what's going on
reject nation the gun guys it's Greg
al-bashir John over here we're here to
have a serious talk about Worf the
planet of eggs a serious movie review so
we can be really respected and as for
intellect yeah movie critics on free
service anyway or for the black hoodie
age we're going to talk about this movie
boy oh boy is this summer not filled
with in every once in a while like once
a month there's a great summer movie
yeah and because you know like May with
Logan June was Wonder Woman and July it
is war for the Planet of the Apes at
least we know so far as we caught an
early screening of this Kristian harloff
Jeremy John's Mark Ellis a lot of people
from Collider they're all in the mood
they're all in the movie they were all
at the movie theater but John and I got
the best seats in the hat' we did and
also a guy named Patrick who's vlogging
on our the name - Patrick we're watching
what's up buddy this movie is a
fantastic experience that's for damn
sure
let me get my quick rundown thoughts on
what I thought about it I thought it was
surprisingly haunting and moving this
special effects oh my god Andy Serkis
annual Sanford Danny Samberg is also in
this and he was a huge comic relief for
the experience of this really brought to
know that he does the rap in the end
credits
yeah it's really cool yeah I really did
enjoy I went to kind of looking forward
to this like I liked on of the Planet of
the Apes I feel like I want to watch
that movie again because that was my
first journey back to that world since
you know I watched the originals as a
kid I was looking forward to this okay I
got something that was really cool it
wasn't quite what I was expecting and
then you like you said like it's easy to
[ __ ] on summertime but every now and
again a gripper like this will come
along it brought me a lot of way then it
really swept me up in it either like it
felt interesting being like this is a
summer film yes it's one of those films
that now we're going into the review
guys my first thought was that song gave
me everything I expected from the
trailer yet something completely
different
yeah yeah well not like everything I
expected plus something completely
different it's like that expectedness
was there but it was just a very
different take on what I expect yeah
yeah like everything most most things in
the trailer are there it's just yeah
it's in between them is like oh wow I
did yeah this is a horror movie
yeah a journey movie you know like
that's one thing I told you like when a
pro is done with this this film sort of
reminded me it feels like a Logan movie
to me yeah kind of infinitely because
they're both apocalyptic Western vibes
throughout the whole film because
they're not exactly in the apocalypse
but it's like borderline a pop go
through it and they also have the really
taking its time Western vibe things get
keep getting worse and worse for a
character's damn dragged through the mud
or snow in this case yeah not as like an
epic you know it is an epic it's an epic
it's a sour that it's sour for what it's
worth
sorrowful sorrowful yes or sorrow I'm
wrong Annunciation are about didn't
suffer folk baleful don't yeah yeah yeah
those folds any of yeah it definitely
has sort of a harried sort of stumbling
you you feel every inch of the journey
with them and yeah the movie locks you
into the Apes perspective this time you
know in a much more focused way which
really makes everything affecting you
know I would totally go it's one of
these kind of movies that has those
throw bones it has some really cool I
guess you'd call them action scenes they
don't even feel like oh cool action
scene they feel like no mistakes you
like the fights are all you know stakes
and so yeah definitely talking about the
action just so you guys don't go in and
come back in this the trailers really
happy believing this is going to be
pretty much war verses aEM's - [ __ ] ton
of action it is not that man wipe you
out so wipe me out here we go what's a
rumble I could only think of maybe two
or three action sequences and a lot of a
lot of that is kind of early on in the
film
for most of it it's really not action
based it's a war movie yes when there's
action there it's pretty freaking cool
like the first sequence they have felt
like this is oh yes the first sequence
because of how early it occurs it makes
you think oh this is what the movies
going to be for most of it just this
like yeah a lot of insane warlike
battles yes but an agent humans but it's
really not that what's much bigger
yet its main plot is also a lot more
personal than the dawn of the Planet of
the Apes
yeah and in multiple ways like I do
appreciate just how much they put into
the facets of the story and the
characters and actually you know
exploring some ideas with this you know
yeah because you know they don't have to
war for the planet a it's you know like
it really bothered to take its time and
you know give you a lot of insight into
what everyone was feeling and what
because it'll about you know like two
species yeah rubbing up against each
other and not being able to you know
coexist and so I guess a high-stakes
situation kind of all the time well Don
of the Planet of the Apes was very much
I felt like it really cut back and forth
a good amount of times we've seen seem
like good humans err perspectives and
then the Apes and what they're going
through and then how that film bill to
something works like oh they're about to
fight it but you really don't want them
to fly because you like I do you guys
use ID and each other agreed yeah that's
really what it feels like in this movie
90% of the time is just dedicated to the
Apes and then the humans you don't
really get to explore a lot of the
humans I mean Woody Harrelson's in this
film has the kernel he is the villain of
the film I love the way they utilize
Aniki I don't want to have any spoilers
away whatsoever about whose character is
how much he's really in the film they
didn't use it the way I was expecting
and the way they did use him I thought
was really cool it was effective for the
big story and yeah including this
trilogy it was it was like the necessary
care a big necessary important character
for this whole for this trilogy to wrap
up and a memorable villain memorable
villain man memorable looks like all of
that horrible gear
no he was a great villain great villain
he's a great like fantastic I forget how
scary Woody Harrelson can actually be to
me this wasn't like oh here he comes -
not like I thought he did a really good
job for this movie he brought a lot of
dimension to that you know in a weird
way because like they allow you to
understand it without ever getting on
board
ya know and it's the glad that's a great
way to put it you know and it's cool
because it's the first time Cesar any
while he had to deal with Koba and you
know the last one in this one it's like
you know these guys are never friends in
the beginning so there are strictly
enemies to each other and for how
personal their rivalry becomes and the
whole arc of it is one of the best
elements of this this really is a
character film from everyone oh yeah
Woody Harrelson's can kernel character
Caesar man today wrap up his character
in such a nice way like in terms of the
trilogy wrapping up I really loved
everything he's so different in each one
of these movies and this one it's it's
like Caesar more he's much more of a
loner in this one he's not yeah a lot of
it the times not dedicated to him you
know spending like gold leading his Apes
throughout along the movie part of the
time the things like bone tomahawk
because well yeah Western because it's
like Caesar he's like I got to do this
thing and a couple of his friends like
nah dude we really want to come help you
and because this little yeah like
traveling band of yeah people on a
mission journey movie like you said yeah
and and that's a cool new direction to
take in to make the movie filled you
know yeah because that was something
that surprised me that I loved about
this was like oh cool like this is
deciding that we're going to see the
movie to the Apes perspective
yeah and that is really effective when
it comes to driving all the point tones
well yeah because the Apes in the movie
they're just characters is this
something that the first two did very
well and this one does even at its best
you really just want the Apes to win
it's just so funny how Planet of the
Apes when that comes on to the scene
like the first movie ever the you know
the 60s movie that movies go and it's
like oh waves are scary we don't want it
to be like we're in Rome we're in
Charlton Heston
using that in that movie yeah and then
when you're watching wrinkles unless I
needed to this one you're like better I
hope they swish yeah we ain't like it's
not going to work out just like you know
it is because it is a prequel yeah but
when you're watching it you can you do
forget that you're so into like how are
they going to do this thing you know I
think they've managed to make and
especially the franchise landscaping of
the Cinematic Universe landscape I think
they've managed to make at least the
ones I've seen feel gripping enough and
I'm not sitting here going where did
this been into all the other movies you
know I was just swept up into this one
yeah you know I was I was locked in on
it I saw the plan of the eight films
growing up you know I am see they have
Marathon them and so like I remember
them being you know more at least
attempting to to be sci-fi into sort of
the use you know metaphors you know
between different cultures in yoga and
so I like that they are really steeping
this movie in that too like this is
about two species you know everybody's
going adding really about its themes and
not excitement but it comes naturally
the exciting because the film is so
tension-filled
it's kind of this is kind of a scary
movie it is yeah because it makes you
feel all this like it forces you to even
everything gets developing its
dimensions yeah even the scariest things
get a moment to be like oh oh I see yeah
nothing is interesting it's one of those
movies that doesn't have like questions
to pay off so much as the situation to
keep developing absolutely no to me the
movie when we're talking about themes
you're bringing up like if it films
really about you know nature mercy
compassion community yeah violence like
will by because it's not the violence is
never cool yeah yeah yeah but I mean
early all of it like it's kind of cool
Italy got all the yeah see that's the
power of a but like that's the I think
the good power of a big studio
blockbuster like this is like even of
money to put the utmost care into
everything that makes it can make a
really great movie until like you list
the action has all the cool [ __ ] it shot
awesome the production values all there
they got helmets with the different
things
on the back and stuff but you still feel
all of it and so it's got the whole
package man that is a whole trailer that
was called meeting bad ape there's a
character in here a Nathan's parents
pretty much Steve song is long I had no
idea was him the entire time I was
watching the film I was like oh he's
awful I had any other students I was
involved in this yeah and this character
was good interesting funny ape character
to have is a brand new way he hasn't
been any planet of the apes movies had
prequels at least I don't know if he
liked make character the other ones I
can't remember her I know he's that
character that could have easily been to
charge our beings or the Dobby a ha of
this of this Apes movie because he
provides a very different tone and style
for for whenever his scenes are present
like there's always a different vibe
when he's around he is kind of like that
panicky character like no I don't want
it then he gets involved I really
enjoyed my speaking through this because
there were times where I like I'm
laughing a little more like we're
laughing a little more than everyone
because part of the thing with a
character like that too is or at least
why it didn't bug me as it seemed to fit
is because I felt like he was just an
odd guy yeah and the humor came from is
being an odd guy and that's kind of just
running into him and sort of no-man's
land
yeah I found it believable that yeah
well you guys just kind of out here the
Apes are treated in total like they're
they're all just they all just a
different looking they're just treated
like another ethnicity okay yeah yeah I
mean I mean in terms of like the
filmmaking writing of the Apes I feel
they're not treated like they're animals
then we show you what lights is likely a
to show you what these characters are
like though they feel like humans they
just look like Apes you know yeah it's
the same reason like an animated movie
works is it just gives them enough to
that it's sort of like here's what their
day is like yeah what the stakes are for
ya you know the scene in the trailer
where that Fame is seen for the tribbles
ends at the waterfall you see that's
there and then Caesar charges at him
while you're shooting that entire
sequence like everything leading up to
that that moment with them the entire
sequence in the cave a rush like a
minute into it a saw went off of my head
this guy's gonna totally pull off that
hey hey if you're somebody's been paying
attention at this guy's next movie is
the Batman and you're not sure because
you're bad reality man can do it yeah
it's never easy to me was one of those
records I'm like I feel like he can do
it I don't really know of anything
specific imagery that I've seen where
I've been like yeah that could be I
could see him doing that way is kind of
style the Batman yeah and then there's
that sequence or like oh yeah this could
be London Ben Affleck has to email gal
gadot more more videos and stuff maybe
he'll use his cloverfield skill that was
even cooler - totally gonna work can't
wait for you to do it Matt Wright it oh
and the little girl oh yeah girl
x-23 is fat cat hi Garrett here for a
little girl right when you write when
you see her in the way they're
introducing character you'll think it -
I might like I was just kinda lookin
x-23 situation but you know I'm with a
different but yeah Caesars daughter she
was made of your DNA James Franco made
her coaches a human with a pavilion from
an alien don't worry buddy
yeah I can't wait for the socratic for
me but would totally in it at theme
Weiser's things yes yeah are very
similar about the little girl yeah I
mean this is like the summer blockbuster
that just gets to is one of the ones
that gets to be a different kind of
movie yeah yeah it's in that sort of
same apocalyptic vibe Oh like an
apocalyptic comic book and you know
she's not she her personality is not
like I don't want people to read too
much embarrassment I'm saying the only
one off her split second up on her
introduction okay it wasn't like the
whole movie what and there's a clause
x-23
it goes in for a movie this somber as
president cry that much but she did have
a scene that did make me cry dude yes
there were yeah there were a couple
moments that got me there were a couple
books this movie really made me feel
stuff like oh yeah when I was there were
times when I was mad like a character's
made me mad then there
times where I was actually really
affected and that goes to the effects
again like I said they're wondering like
some of this has got to be real right
some of the time a suits or anthropic so
good it wasn't like you can spend your
time with a completely age cast and it's
still affecting a close-up on my age is
talking for a while and like I swear
that's practical effect is something I
don't know how the technology works but
like there's something about that that
avoids the uncanny valley and like I can
just emotionally invest in a penis -
yeah knowing everything feels I feel and
stuff at all it's interesting to me
because when I heard they were rebooting
it with rides
one thing that upset me when I saw the
treasures wasn't like they're not going
a practical effect a so so far will make
the magic of the Planet of the Apes an
open Zimmern's unlike those effects were
so pretty cool yeah yeah makeup man is
that it is not a thing that even
concerns you the slightest in this
movement no a they have to move more
like Apes so that's an important factor
to happen said but yeah I think whatever
looks like an intuitive knowledge see
the motion capture here really make like
everything is on the red lip is
groundbreaking yeah you're like in order
to do this I understand why you needed
these yes and also just I think they
look yeah I'm here like a 90 95 eight
cents what is that eight money yeah I
give it a hundred fifty bananas and ten
of those exploding gas tanks 154 then
subscribe to the real real Jack Jack
click that notification Mel this handle
is that John Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram as a social media manager of
blonde outhouse and you could check out
all our awesome exclusive perks and
rewards video content over at our pastry
filled and having a lot of fun time
interacting with the folks over there
folks they're all 80 years old they are
my relative
okay top of the patreon the octogenarian
rejects yes and they give me my
allowance every month through patreon
let me look at the mass steady diet of
mashed potatoes and day-old bread crumbs